[Music]
lion dancing dates back to the Tang
Dynasty in China I was really meant to
war off the evil spirits and welcome the
good ones I am a 20-something year old
millennial but I still hold this piece
of tradition grab three rings and make
three lines I was born and raised in
Chinatown we do have a lot of the
Chinese traditions that they've come
over and carried on and passed on to us
why Nancy is really important to China
because it is a traditional sport it's
something that a lot of people do come
out and they celebrate around Chinese
New Year typically includes at least two
people per set and a lion you'll have
somebody who plays the lion head and
then somebody will play the tail when
you first come in and you walk through
the door you can't just make up a lion
head it takes about a year for you to be
able to work your way up to that level
kung-fu is the foundation of lion dance
their stances and their leg work is
extremely important we're having you
trained in your footwork in your stances
making sure that you're strong enough to
physically hold yourself through routine
but also a lion head because the lion
head is heavy it's typically anywhere
between 15 to 30 pounds
[Music]
typically we teach different routines
for each of the Lions just because you
never know which one you're going to
play it
you can see this line dancing in the
streets anytime where there is a
community event will usually partaking
them in Chinatown a lot of people are
familiar with line dancing and they get
really pumped and excited for it so just
the energy in the atmosphere for me is
ten times better
it's really important for all of us of
that we are educated about line dancing
we do carry it on just because it is
kind of a lost art here in America
for me when I do have children one day I
would like to pass that on to them as
well I think it's really important I
think it's what makes our family our
family
[Music]
I've always had that inner fire in me
like I gotta prove them wrong you know
[Music]
that comes from my thing my hip-hop
spirit a little bit I'm not gonna wait
for that mic to be passed to me I have
to like grab my name is Jonathon Park
also known as dumbfounded a rapper based
out of Los Angeles California I grew up
in front of the television you know my
whole personality is based off of like
sitcoms from the 90s you know I started
having interests in entertainment it
started getting a little discouraging
because I wouldn't see anybody on
television or films that look like me
and that's when I started to be going a
little bit more aggressive with
everything I do yeah
daddy was G granddaddy was G - they
never bang when I started hopping on
stages or when I got a microphone I
wanted to be loud and I wanted to be
heard and I wanted to be outlandish and
say crazy stuff you know and that's kind
of what built this confidence in me to
pursue rat and rap the things that I
want to talk about yeah
the song in music video safe is pretty
much my response to the whitewashing of
Asians in Hollywood or any minority in
the entertainment industry and I wanted
to kind of come at it aggressively on
the song that now we aren't you know the
model minority we have things to say and
you're gonna hear a rebuttal if you
attack us growing up with a very
traditional Korean American family in
the household being involved in music
and arts that was a rare thing at the
time for Asian parents to accept
when they turned on the television saw
no Asians on TV they were like there's
no money in this you know what I mean
but growing up in Koreatown gave me tons
of confidence confidence of Who I am as
a person being a strong korean-american
without feeling like an outsider and
that's a responsibility on its own to
take that influence around me and
translate it into my art and share these
stories of my people all across you know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hula is the language of the heart and
therefore the heartbeat of the Hawaiian
people and we tell our dancers
everything needs steps your hair your
torn nail your eyelashes it needs to
dance now you only go if I say no
[Music]
[Applause]
within three days the competition
tickets are sold out those tickets are
like gold they only bring the best of
the best and so we're very honored to be
able to participate the most prestigious
part of Merrie Monarch is the miserable
hula competition which is the women's
solo competition 12 hollows are allowed
to choose their very best answer our
contestant this year is chemical any car
can you many is a professional hula
dancer and which was heard for many
different reasons we wanted to pretty
cool
not just the dancer but as a person you
had no cold yeah one of my favorite
parts about Merrie Monarch week is that
we go to Kilauea to pay respects to Pele
with the fire goddess I got a self
secretion and it really puts into
perspective where you are in this world
and in this pool of journey
[Music]
I've wanted to be in Mary marks since I
was a little kid there was a lot of
times where I thought I would never they
would never happen for me but pretty
much most of my hula journey has been
working towards this moment which is
tomorrow professionally I've been doing
it since 2009 there's a difference
between dancing hula and Hollow and
dancing with a professional dancing for
the Taurus is like American Chinese and
not the authentic Chinese food and
hotels here's what you see beautiful men
and women brightly colored hair pieces
and leis which are all plastic but you
won't see the skill you won't see the
love that you would at the Merrie
Monarch festival for Merrie Monarch we
practice every day for I would say three
to four months they're intense can we
try to end one more time what you think
waiting invitation you need one
invitation come on you guys get your
head game on the biggest misconception
about hula I said it's easy all hula
dancers and Yuko be honest have bad
knees all of them so when you see a
beautiful hula dancer it's gliding
across the stage she's hurting she's
hurting really bad because nobody walks
around with bent knees you know six
inches off the ground blisters you get
blisters on your feet every single part
of your body needs to work you should be
gasping for air but you can you need to
look exactly the same as when you first
started if you can bend your knees and
swing your hips
have this upper-body carriage that's
really upgrade but make it look
effortless that's what you wanna mention
ladies and gentlemen welcome to this
Aloha Hula competition if I gave the
performance of a lifetime if I gave
everything I had to that one performance
those 14 minutes up there just me
you're just the vessel for all of these
people that came before you for all of
the knowledge that you have and it's
your responsibility to share that it's
your responsibility to perpetuate but it
would be so nice to hear my name being
called
I know ladies and gentlemen mr. Avila
for 2016 Kaylee
[Applause]
you know I don't dance hula just to be a
missile Ola I do it because I just
because I love it and III can explain to
you why I do I think I think it's
something you just learn
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what if I told you some of the best
Indian food in LA is next to this busy
highway at a gas station inside a
convenience store this guy certainly
likes it let's see how this plate of
Indian burritos ended up near the Dorito
aisle at the bomb bay Frankie company
you'll find Hiram and his staff making
Indian food at a gas station
Hiram care to explain okay the reason
why we chose this particular gas station
is because our families actually in the
gas station gave me a store business we
had this space for you for quite a while
and we thought well what a great
launchpad traditionally what you might
find it is unhealthy non fresh fare and
when you're coming across something
that's not only fresh but it's true to
the most raw ingredients so when we
start with that completely off the wall
pairing you're gonna be starting from a
really low point so all you can go is
high and higher and we're trying to just
set the bar really high since they've
opened the Bombay Frankie company has
received both critical and commercial
success definitely our most popular item
is the Frankie in Bombay sometimes it
can be a rolled-up sandwiches sometimes
it can be an enclosed sandwich what we
try to do is make it ultimately
relatable to the LA market and make it
really similar to a burrito it's one of
the best things you've ever tried people
say never mix business with friends or
family I say don't knock it until you
try it
the key members of the bumpy Frankie
company it's my sister Priyanka please
our esteemed chef mr. kuhmo Jeet Singh
and our staff having someone come in for
the first time who's never tried Indian
food and are completely engulfed by the
experience they truly realized that not
only is it an Indian food coming from a
gas station and being served in the gas
station
that they would try it elsewhere so by
preserving traditional ingredients
tradition corporations traditional
recipes were staying true to not only
ourselves but the region of food for
which we serve and we want to make sure
that you're leaving feel like you got
the true experience there are countless
Chinatown's all over the world
in new york boasts one of the most
famous full of cheap produce fish
markets and of course a plethora of
Chinese food but if you hop on the one
train take it to the Upper West Side
you'll find a Chinese restaurant like no
other where half the menu is something
else to ellipta chicharonnes ropa vieja
first Oni are gross III honey this is la
caridad 78 New York's last Cuban Chinese
restaurant comida China Grill oh yeah
three oh yeah
how did this unlikely culinary duo come
to be it's a great question
enter Sam Lee sorry my wife remember
father came over here or he started I
like his own restaurant would you like
Cuban spices and also the Chinese put
mix together hundreds of thousands of
Chinese came to Cuba in the 19th and
early 20th century establishing a strong
presence on the island but when Castro
came to power most Chinese immigrants
like Sam's father left many of them
coming to the u.s. and thus Cuban
Chinese food was born I would say
luckily the restaurant is not restaurant
is a kitchen for Upper West siders we
have oxtail robbery
which is like a shredded beef at the
same time we search a nice food either
cooked from ie Romanian from China and
they learn the train when they got here
and it become very good so are there any
Cuban born workers left I still have a
one kilburn worker working for me again
I see enemy Kamino Miyagi my name is
Antonia Wong I work in the career I'm a
star in 1986 I'm born in a harmonica in
1951
and every analyst key1 work invisible
while Cuban Chinese culture is fading la
caridad is a snapshot of a strange
moment in time where two vastly
different cultures merged together the
Cuban Chinese people getting older and
they don't have any younger people to
take over I myself felt like I all my
father who started this restaurant so I
wanted to try to make sure that I carry
on the tradition for him
[Music]